[Music]
what is up
bonky you're my new favorite
in the whole world minecart monkey
except
you suck man don't don't listen to him
garbage i wish you drowned that's a
weird insult
anyway is it time to build a meatball
nah you know what time it is it's time
to make some goddamn potions
first off though let me show you guys i
made automatic farms
look at this i spent all morning on this
how is it doing
are they making bread oh they make bread
they don't make weed
stop it some of them got trapped some of
the demetrius
building redstone is boring it's fun to
watch it work
it's like watching someone program here
here's the result look it works
cool right yeah anyway let's do
something
exciting i want to go back in the nether
but first
let me check on this disgusting
despicable creature
lee leave us i don't want you here
ill you're disgusting you know this is
sewage water right yeah
run straight from my house down here i
hope you enjoy yourself
you piece of trash you piece of
sewage anyway let's make some mother
flipping potion ah let me smack that ass
top of the morning yeah this is my
brewing stand
wow it looks so good oh we need a
cauldron
i remember in my brain how to make a
caldron because you make caldrons
it's upside down pants
[Music]
you just change that you got paints now
you got kettlebell baby
sweet uh i need vials as well i had the
glass i'm gonna make some fire rest
potion we're gonna make some healing
potion
we're gonna potion some ocean in the
ocean from my
lotion in my [ __ ] you all right that's
it what do you think of the new face cam
pretty close to face reveal i'm
revealing hair reveal today
so yeah that's a big move we're taking
steps i'm becoming more and more
comfortable
showing my face online i don't know how
i do it
yeah that looks good i like the caldron
in here because it
really brings out the place you know
makes it nice and cozy in here
vial how do i spell vial veil file
bottle it's a bottle it's not a vial
minecraft learn english please that's
kind of cringe
so i never really messed around with
potions a lot wait
clearly because i they're empty
oh i got an achievement for that nice
yeah i feel like i wait
it takes water from it then what's the
point of a caldron i thought
what is that a new thing what the [ __ ]
is the point of a calendar and then
that's so garbage oh my god i gotta get
more water now
it's not your fault it's not your fault
donkey
bonky yeah that looks good
i'll fix it later dude i've been getting
so many comments complaining about my
story system
i i get it but also like how much
does it need to be like uh
shut up basically is what i'm saying all
right i'll get some use out of this
caldron look
thanks caldron now you work like you're
supposed to
that's so dumb anyway uh for those of
you who don't know potions this might be
good to know
you make it into an awkward potion yeah
yeah i need magma cream where is it
i should oh god where is it i have it oh
no i i know for a fact
i have magma okay maybe i do need to
fix my storage
i think it's in my nether box down there
all right i'll get it later
okay fine i'll organize my storage i'm a
point taken
now that i have potions i could actually
go to different places like the woodland
temple
uh the water temple i feel a little bit
more comfortable with it
with the gear i have as well i think i
can do it i guess i can make health
potions how do you do that i think
that's glowstone no
glistening melon that's right shoot and
then you increase the potency with
blood yes i know relax relax
is it better to do splash one i guess
it's quicker i'll make some splash once
i think you add gunpowder to it to make
splash
this is fun okay so now we have healing
we'll increase the power of it with a
glowstone
we'll go in the nether in a sec you got
i got gotta be prepared man
i ain't going there without fire
assistant shut up
he keeps trying to meow you can't meow
your way out of this one
i understand before you were in
disgusting ugly sheep
and now you changed i swear i had it
maybe in the nether oh i would hey
hey hey do not go near alabama alabama
are we gonna walk in here dumbass what
is happening
please be here oh my god i totally lost
i totally lost it that sucks
it's okay it's okay alabama it's okay
it's not your fault
really glad i built this railroad road
system i i know how to fix it at least
so don't comment
why did i put it there idiot felix okay
cool sweet we're good we're back in
action so
we have a good one now i love how that
works better
than using the caldron i don't get it
anyway let's use the magma cream such a
gross name i don't like it
i don't want to get drink cream doesn't
feel good
it doesn't feel good i'll drink g fuel
okay
and then you extend the the length of
the potion from three minutes to eight
minutes
with the redstone dust i know minecraft
i don't know why i've never done this
sort of stuff before it's so helpful
when you're playing hardcore you want
every help you can get and i'm doing it
i'm not gonna die
it's not happening forget about the
gamers
okay cool we have three of them wait you
can make a
potion of slow falling what would be the
point i
there's no way i would have time to
drink it maybe that's good for the
dragon fight because he launches you in
the air
but i don't see myself needing that why
would i need that
oh my god that's gonna be a clip in case
i die from a cliff or something
okay so if my calculations are correct
this will become splash ones
yeah it worked sweet okay i think that's
all i need for now
so yeah the idea is if i ever fall in
lava slurp slip slurp
or if i ever die just throw that [ __ ]
that's the idea
which won't happen you know i really
don't need this
i'm just using them so people don't
feel bad about badness
anyway i just remember something because
i kept trying to make a bow i need a bow
if i'm gonna go to nether
right yes yes yes i have a trident
i completely forgot because i put it in
the meatball but considering how i lose
everything
i don't know where i put it it could be
anywhere i will finish the meatball
okay i get it i i need to finish it
where is it there you are my girl
oh you've taken a lot of damage oh i
don't like that
and we're gonna put mending on you don't
worry girl oh now i feel like myself
again
ah it ain't minecraft without the
trident
all right we're gonna enchant the [ __ ]
out of this baby because today i
came prepared you will see in a second
all of them escaped by the way when i
was trying to move out some villagers
it was a goddamn nightmare i need a
trapdoor there
anyhow what are you looking at
i see i got infinity i was like yes but
i couldn't get power
impaling five i got impaling five and i
was like i haven't tried it
all right so let's get impaling and
let's find mending
loyalty give me give me give me give me
give me give me
back off cheeky you're not the
protagonist of this anime chiquita oh
actually i need that too thank you oh
god i'm broke now
damn i'm putting all of this what does
channeling do
is that the lightning one i want it i
want it now i forgot about that
oh my god yes back to my god church
i just kissed your peepee it's nothing
like it was weird but let's keep moving
oh
this is my favorite room okay loyalty
and unbreaking mending
impaling ah see oh level one
oh level two whoa whoa whoa whoa it's
going too fast i know
no one's ever done this oh five already
just 20 more oh looks like i'm stabbing
my church i would never hurt you church
never what the more watercats
this is unacceptable get out of my pool
oh you made that you made a hole in it
oh
you're trapped forever watercat evil
you're evil
once i have loyalty on this thing
no you made me waste my post god
damn it you piece of [ __ ]
ah
[Music]
i hate watercats
i'm furious i'm shaking dude you can't
see it because i
have a hidden face cam but my god uh
no time for sleeping go back to work i
need to trade you
all right 17 not bad not bad
there's a zombie out there where
i will zombify them i know that you can
do that i just
i haven't had time there's too much to
do which actually makes me happy because
that means i can play this game forever
help help oh my gosh i never had this
much problem there we go
ah it's watercat's fault i know it
whoa what the hell
ah the sewage water save me where are
they coming from
did i get raided why are there so many
zombies
well i'll take it it makes me level up
oh my god
is this a zombie raid
a spider raid 20. cool
all right now i can sleep
get out my bed
yeah oh yeah you like that let's grab my
homie and let's get some more glass
where is he bonky my main
bonky way your way i let him ride free
but i don't know where he is
let's check how these guys are doing
oh my god it's working really well well
done guys
are you having fun oh he's sounding
super fun
uh yeah i got this farm design from mr
cat
on youtube it's really good except they
make bread and i don't understand why
stop making bread i won't we it's like a
two minute video how to make it and i'm
like what
usually every time i look up a tutorial
on minecraft it's like
hey guys remember to subscribe so anyway
we're gonna make this fun today and
be sure to check out my other channel
where i make blah blah and then it goes
on for 20 minutes and you just like just
make the
thing but he didn't have that so i
that's why i want to give it a shot
because
someone finally gets it honestly i don't
think i need to build like an xp farm
because this is
pretty bomb way to get money in xp
oh my gosh i'm so close are you kidding
me
[Music]
i can't believe i healed that cat
disgusting all right bonky seriously i'm
getting worried where's bonky
where is bonky oh okay there he is
bonky my man
best boy my anime girlfriend my
minecraft anime girlfriend right here
bonky
he's the best dude
yeah nothing turns me on like that sound
don't tell mercy
look at this oh perfect 360.
i might have to break my shovel now yeah
that's right bonky you and me baby oh
he's helping me
oh yeah over here bunky you want me over
here all right you got it fam
no problem this shovel is a weapon of
mass destruction
i don't technically have to need to do
this but i i enjoy it
it's so satisfying you carry my stuff
bunky what is this you don't need this a
bonky
yeah he's so tough he's got a thick ass
and he carries my stuff he's
bunky monkey
that's beautiful thank you one day
i'll get so much sand that i let up the
entire god church
is this dangerous by the way like could
the floor collapse or something
nah bonky's here he would stop it from
happening
everyone say uh rest in peace shovel
it's okay bunky i got you what the heck
is happening
i need to make it so bonky can fit in
but he can't
and he breaks my heart i didn't even
need him
hey you can carry my cactus monkey i'll
need it later actually
one day glorious furnace house will burn
and god himself will return see i built
this as a meme but it's actually coming
really handy
i don't think i need that many but still
but still
all right just so i can flex on you poor
poor people
let me make another shovel i had one
ready actually nine
fine don't care see i was thinking about
putting
trees inside them and then i can build
another meeple in the air
and another in the air and have all the
different biomes
in caps that could be cool i got so much
stuff i want to do with this world
i just really hope i don't die
it's just like real life you know
i want to go to japan but sure hope i
don't die before
you guys are killing it i actually like
that all of them are stuck in there
because it's kind of annoying how they
were all
how did they all get in i didn't mean to
trap all of them why don't we chop some
wood
why am i more efficient in minecraft
than in real life
i feel like probably a lot of people
relate to that well the most efficient
way to do this is
meanwhile have to do something at home
i'll just put it off it's whatever
haha relatable hey can't do this on
bedrock version
i don't need this much account akatcha
is it a catcher
acacia whatever no one cares i think
maybe in the future
i'll do something with it i don't know
maybe you guys have some suggestions
i already built a japanese temple but oh
look at him
look at his little face is sticking out
that's so cute it doesn't look great
from here but
it looks great from the top so i don't
know i like it but maybe in the future
i'll
turn it into something else gotta finish
the meatball first like this has a
really good feeling to me
it's cool view and good storage all
right wake the frick ups
samurai i don't know why he's giving me
a discount
i haven't treated you well at all i
don't get it
yeah nice
not bad not bad at all pp thunder
that's a cool name it costs one more
level
but god damn it's worth it i also saw i
got cancelled
recently because uh youtubers were mad
about me using
a face i don't know what to call it like
an anime filter
which is amazing my
special favorite comment was the ones
complaining that it was an
ugly enemy
but i might make a video on it it's so
funny but
i like this thing people go through the
extra mile of hiding their appearance
online
so they can cr criticize other people's
fake appearances
online they're like wow okay
basically you break my heart all right i
spent five minutes all night
and you just criticize it let's see is
it going up
it is sweet wait it might be
that was so easy it might be worth
putting mending on all my stuff then
yeah that's gotta be cheaper than paying
19 levels every time to make a new one
yeah i just have to heal them how much
does that cost two
okay yes ah
no my ah still worth it
so anyway we're gonna go to the nether
oh it's so cozy in here i love it love
love love it
let's see this is the last enchantment i
want to make yes
we're gucci i i'm stacked out i just
need more nether right
okay let's test that oh it's about to
get nice perfect we can test that
oh wow look at you
trying to escape
let's test out my fishing rod first of
all i need name tags
so bad that's the thing in bedrock that
is better you can fish
so much faster holy come on
i got a raw kind oh look at this
i have a fish you're hungry
oh i feel so bad for you
oh i got another fish yummy yummy yummy
i know you're not even trying to escape
oh look at this fish
so good fine you can have one but i
throw away the other ones
my empathy is too strong let's ride out
with you again
let's go my man oh we got some big boys
oh i got an achievement for that i
didn't know that
full enchanted armor back up
nice so i think it'll do well oh there's
a lot of them
hey careful
nice shoot
god you're so annoying
yeah don't worry about you're getting i
don't need help
how many are there
shoot so three shots yeah
oh he's riding a spider isn't that super
rare
stop it ah
i guess my sword is still better oh my
god
nice pants bro
whoa maybe maybe not maybe not
jesus christ
okay we're going back we're going back
note taken
oh look at me dude
why am i on fire this is where i'll die
oh but you can't even shoot me from that
range [ __ ]
oh god i hate the arrow ones are the
worst
i mean creepers are pretty bad
oh you can't hit me neither can i
stop strafing bro stop he's strafing
get out of here god you little snake i
see you let's get the snake come here
come here wait i hit the torch
come here [ __ ]
why is he invisible what
i never seen this ever why
what that is so creepy
is that a glitch damn it looks so cool i
never i never seen this or at least in a
long time
it's still night how you doing man
pathetic okay so now if i throw it away
it will just like circulate around me
yeah
[Music]
yeah give me a massage oh a head massage
so
jurgen where did he go oh my gosh
come back looks so insane ah yes my
head's
head's so itchy thank you thank you
loyal you're so loyal
we doing here again oh my god a
thunderstorm please
i don't have shadowing it won't matter
but it would be pretty cool
what up schmonkey so cozy
i love it hell it's about time
this feels very anime here again i will
make it back
because this time i do what i'm doing
i offer wood planks please bless this
journey across
gosh should i hey him
how you doing
cool that's my attic are we cool
i didn't kill anyone trust me all right
just realized they can totally enter
from there okay let's grab some
let's place oh sorry i i
uh i didn't do that i swear
i swear i had nothing to do with it
okay so if i drink this
let's have a potion of healing ready but
i should be able to go
oh it feels so warm and nice come join
me oh it's like a japanese onsen
it's 5 32 right now so i can swim
oh my god this is [ __ ] up
why is this a thing oh my god i'm so
slow
hey hey
can i hold my breath under lava what i
can breathe in lava
that's epic maybe not the most efficient
but at least
we've taken out a threat you know i
don't have to worry about falling in
lava
i'm still on fire unfazed
what up gamers don't worry allah ma'am
i'm like this is fine meme get out of my
house
man oh that was too fast
shoot oh god did it fall down
not a problem oh i actually hurt myself
a little bit
all right let's not mess around too much
i did a little mean guys i did a little
meme all right
how do i get back up what are you gonna
do
they do do a lot of damage not gonna lie
are you mad
bye bye bridge i hear him dying oh
[Laughter]
i thought it was lava see this stuff
i've been
terrified of fixing now it's like yeah
whatever
[Music]
whoa that's a lot of damage
why am i taking so much damage okay
maybe not get too cocky damn all right
let me just mine this
oh [ __ ] i didn't think of that i didn't
think of this am i making you guys
anxious
nah impossible that would make you
cowards
so i have like one minute left on the
potion
plenty of time guys it'd be great to
find the green version of the red biome
that we're in
i don't know what it's called like the
enderman one this is good too actually
because now we can find some magma cream
here right
oh oh i know gas can spawn here
hold up can't they break these i'm sure
it's fine
whoa oh so creepy
see there they are uh i do need them
should i go down here
yeah it looks safe yes why not
i was crazy when i started this up like
actually insane why is the nether so
scary man
i can't do this man blackstone looks
cool i might use that
i should be building my bridges out of
these then
oh [ __ ] i've been here before
where does this go obviously i've been
here before oh my gosh this is the
[Applause]
what is this this is a flower biome
sweet i could actually use some
well this place is lovely why didn't i
build a base here
my beautiful dirt house thank you thank
you
it's funny completely forgot
there's no gas here so i might as well
use this
if i don't look not looking down
actually helps
strange all right there we go there are
guests here oh
let's keep going further than no man
has ever gone before
all right that was fun i joked about
doing this before but now i'm just like
i don't care
holy [ __ ] dude rest in peace pickaxe
there we go
another one wow ah come on give me
another biome
i'm getting hypnotized oh new biome
yeah i'll check it out all right i'm not
afraid
we got bone blocks i'll take some bone
thank you is this
okay i would have been fine oh my god
another
another are you serious another what is
this luck dude
i've been running five minutes straight
and i'm not even
come on the real reason i came here was
for more magma cream
yeah this place sucks all right i'm
gonna drink it
that's too much lava around here
i actually need to help him come up
why is he not attacking me no the magma
cream
can i still get it
come back to me this is like a bad idea
i'm going up
dang it i need you to not drop the stuff
in the lava please
he actually does a lot of damage holy
crap
there's a magma nice oh there's more
excellent
oh my god they dropped so much yes this
is just what i wanted
bro i don't know what's stopping you
oh what else hitting me another one
oh nightmare
nightmare i mean a perpetual nightmare
holy [ __ ] dude oh
god real go go go go go this this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] damn
i'm gonna deal with you guys despite the
risk
i don't know if they dropped it i just
want you to die
all right i am done seven
i'll take it i'm i'm adios
damn that was scary dude thank the lord
for a fire potion
i want to watch a replay on that but i
looked insane
oh man i'm so dumb i should have
realized the gravel oh
of course a challenge on the way back
fine
god damn they don't hold back
oh my god you okay buddy
you guys see that
he's fine kids trust me home sweet home
alabama alabama thank you for blessing
me alabama
thank you i know alabama i'm going i'll
see you next time
oh it feels good to be back what are we
learning today
drink your goddamn fire potions
thanks for watching the video smash like
subscribe
you know what it is see you in the next
one ruffus
people agree because i'm mine all day
i'm mine all night till those diamonds
[Music]
i'm